hier soir après l'interview du président
de la République diffusé sur TF1 il y a
une casserolade qui commence on connaît
maintenant avec une dizaine d'individus
il décide d'aller viser la chocolaterie
trop nulle il y a plusieurs
chocolateries en France ça fait
plusieurs semaines quels sont la cible
de Pierre là en l'occurrence c'était des
jets de poubelle le petit neveu qui
habite au premier étage de cette
chocolaterie en temps ce qui est en
train de se passer descend pour empêcher
qu'on saccage son magasin et là il est
passé à tabac disons-le il reçoit des
coups notamment à la tête et sur les
jambes il a passé un scanner aujourd'hui
selon les informations du service police
justice de cnews il aurait quatre jours
d’été donc voilà il a voulu s'interposer
la première dame a réagi en saluant son
courage celui d'avoir voulu empêcher la
lâcheter la bêtise et donc il a été
évidemment victime de violence Emmanuel
Macron a réagi aussi depuis l'Islande où
il se trouve actuellement il a réagi en
tant qu'oncle et en tant que président
de la République il a expliqué que c'est
parce que c'était
à Lille dans une autre chocolaterie qui
a été vandalisée je cite deux points
Pender Macron ça pose la question de la
responsabilité politique j'ai passé ma
journée à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui alors tout le monde condamne
il y a uneanimité tout le monde condamne
à gauche à droite mais là où les partis
politiques s'opposent c'est qui est
responsable du climat de violence
aujourd'hui en France on a vu ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière avec le
maire de Saint-Brévin qui a démissionné
ce qui a plusieurs semaines sont
domicile a été incendié ces voitures ont
été incendiées et là effectivement
l'extrême gauche a pointé l'extrême
droite et aujourd'hui c'est l'inverse
c'est-à-dire que je sais pas si vous
vous rappelez ce conseiller régional
elle est fille de France Monsieur
prud'hommes qui avait dit Louis XVI on
l'a décapité c'est ça Macron peut
recommencer ça aussi est-ce que ça
attise la haine et la violence
la question vous avez compris
sur une chaîne d'info concurrente
aujourd'hui en condamnant évidemment la
violence est-ce qu'il a aussi une
responsabilité dans violence qu'on
traverse quand il pose avec la tête
sur un ballon en dessous de son pied
exactement il y a sans doute aussi une
responsabilité politique l'extrême
gauche dit que c'est à cause du
gouvernement et de sa réforme des
retraites l'extrême droite dit que c'est
à cause de l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
gauche dit que c'est à cause de
l'extrême droite on le sait on vous l'a
dit ici c'est vrai que la réforme des
retraites voilà ça nous plaît pas on le
dit et moi j'aime les gens qui vont
manifester j'aime les gens qui sont pas
d'accord qui disent ils sont pas
d'accord mais faire ça le petit il a une
chocolaterie on va saccager la
chocolaterie parce qu'il est de la
famille Emmanuel Macron on est on vit
dans quelle ville c'est n'importe quoi
ça excusez-moi franchement ça c'est
c'est les faibles qui font ça avec voilà
c'est c'est c'est les 100 couilles pour
moi qui font ça voilà je vous dis la
vérité c'est les 100 couilles s'attaquer
à eux c'est vraiment c'est voilà c'est
des lâches et pour moi la lâcheté je
déteste ça non mais c'est vrai c'est
vraiment c'est l'âge de faire ça et je
pense à lui le pauvre pauvre il a rien
fait il se retrouve avec un scanner bah
bien sûr non mais c'est toujours du tété
mais je vous dis qu'on soit pas d'accord
avec
tout ce qui se passe avec le
gouvernement avec qu'on aimerait qu'il
fasse plus on le dit tous les jours ici
on essaie de faire avancer les choses et
voilà il y a plein de gens qui sortent
dans la rue et qui font valoir leur
désapprobations mais je vous dis ce qui
se passe et tu as raison les deux
exemples que tu as cité c'est
inadmissible que les mecs disent ça on a
des capitaux Louis XVI on peut décapiter
Macron je suis désolé c'est un appel à
la violence le mec qui avait la tête du
ministre de du ministre du Travail voilà
sur exactement voilà sur ça c'est
insupportable l'image elle est terrible
l'image tu te dis quoi et aujourd'hui
condames les violences bah oui mais il
sera peut-être pas compte où il fait
semblant de pas se rendre compte
climat actuel contrairement si j'étais
eux je ferme ma gueule je condamne rien
du tout parce que c'est quand on a fait
ce qu'ils ont fait ils disent rien c'est
beaucoup mieux que de condamner les
violences et de dire après oui mais je
condamne les violences quand tu fais ça
c'est violent que je suis désolé de ne
pas le faire le truc du ballon de
football mais c'est bien de condamner
aussi mais le mieux ce serait pas de
faire le truc devant tout le là c'est la
détresse de gens qui sont énervés et qui
veulent s'en prendre à la famille pour
pouvoir taper le président mais là vous
tapez pas le président ce que c'est
condamnable et moi je je suis contre ce
genre de fait moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir ce qui va ce qui va ce
qu'ils vont prendre ce qu'on va arrêter
s'ils ont été arrêté
la reconductible 24 heures je pensais
qu'il va m'intéresser j'aimerais bien
savoir
on va voir on va voir le truc de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon après écouter le
témoignage du père un neveu de Brigitte
Macron euh voilà regardez des
commentaires indifférents tentatives de
meurtre et d'agression raciste sont des
contre des insoumis me somme de me
prononcer sur l'agression à Amiens
contre le chocolatier trogneux ça ça va
pas déjà nous sommes ça va responsable
politique qui est à l'assemblée qui est
que des gens n'écoute et le suivent ça
va pas ça le chocolatier trogneux ça va
pas c'est une barre de la boutique
peut-être mais ça va vraiment on m'a
obligé à présenter donc ça veut dire
qu'il avait pas envie de réagir qui
n'avait pas du tout envie
il vaut mieux ne rien mettre ça veut
dire on m'a sommet de réagir et de dire
voilà
c'est mieux il risque jusqu'à 3 ans de
prison et 45000 € d'amende max alors je
demande à Macron et Madame d'en faire
autant pour nos amis agresser ou menacés
sont réserve sans réserver leur
signification
alors le père de Jean-Baptiste qui a été
agressé à témoigner dans plusieurs
médias on va l'écouter d'abord il
explique ce qui s'est passé regarde hier
soir après la location du président sur
TF1 une manifestation en non autorisée a
eu lieu dans le centre ville d'Amiens
d'une quarantaine de personnes
mon fils rentrait vers 22h et il ouvre
la porte à ce moment-là une dizaine
d'individus qui le reconnaissent comment
ça l'insulter et se jette sur lui le
roux quand je pour le coup c'est des
coups de poing dans la figure à
plusieurs reprises ils l'ont jeté au sol
et ils l'ont tabassé avec des des coups
de pieds dans la tête dans la tempe dans
les doigts dans les bras enfin bref une
vraie FG et il doit son secours aux
voisins d'en face qui courageusement ses
déplacer avec ses enfants et ses fils
plutôt pour éloigner les agresseurs et
qu'ils puissent rentrer chez lui il a de
la chance d'avoir un qui bouge
exactement alors Jean-Baptiste a pu
passer plusieurs examens aujourd'hui
sont perds détails les blessures écoutez
en train de passer un scanner cérébral
il y a une commission il y a plusieurs
doigts qui sont abîmés il y a des côtes
cassés c'est pratique c'est absolument
scandaleux
alors Jean-Baptiste est désormais le
propriétaire de cette chocolaterie qui a
été transmise de génération génération
et elle est cible de nombreux attaques
depuis et c'est pas la seule parce que
je crois qu'il y a 7 établissements en
tout dans le nord de la France les
chocolats il y en a plusieurs et comme
je vous disais notamment à Lille j'ai lu
avant de venir un PV de police qui
faisait état de ce qui s'était passé à
Lille là c'était des pavés qui avaient
été jetés sur la vitrine donc évidemment
vous imaginez les dommages et encore une
fois il y avait eu taguer je cite
pendais Macron regardez regardez
entreprise l'entre-deux lui appartient
depuis l'année dernière et non pas au
président et à la famille du président
comme on va le prendre donc c'était lui
à lui personne d'autre et ça c'est un
point d'orgue depuis l'élection 2017 sur
le nombre d'agressions ça a été des
insultes des crachats des des
dégradations de nos magasins et là
maintenant on arrive à l'insoutenable
c'est l'agression physique on a eu ici
des bombes lacrymogènes qui ont été
jetés à l'intérieur du magasin on a eu
des enfumages dans le magasin de la
cathédrale on a eu des tag s sur
certains de magasins et il y a moins
d'un mois les toutes les vitrines du
magasin de Lille ont été fracassées donc
oui on a c'est c'est exponentiel et là
on atteint un stade qui est
insupportable
alors
et sur la responsabilité politique parce
que c'était tout à l'heure effectivement
deux exemples on peut remarquer qu'à
chaque fois ils ont un problème avec la
décapitation c'est à dire avec la
terreur les insoumis c'est-à-dire qu'il
y en a qui se revendiquent de
Robespierre période de la terreur donc
on a des capitaux à tour de bras et où
robespierre a terminé lui-même décapité
je sais pas ce qu'ils ont avec la
décapitation on chante Louis 16 on a
décapité Macron peut recommencer on pose
avec la tête la fosse tête d'Olivier du
saupoud sur un ballon il y a quelque
chose qui les fascine dans la guillotine
et dans la décapitation alors ils sont
père a appelé donc les anti Macron à ne
pas faire d'amalgame entre les membres
de sa famille et la chocolaterie de son
fils on peut pas faire un amalgame entre
une famille et tous les mondes de sa
famille il s'agit pas de politique
on est en démocratie tout le monde on a
le droit de de penser de respecter ce
qu'il a envie de faire mais à aucun
moment on a le droit de faire un
amalgame comme celui-ci et taper
agresser insulter voir maintenant
maintenant sur des des faits graves de
de violence un membre de la famille sous
prétexte qui fait partie de la famille
du président ça c'est inadmissible et
est-ce qu'on a des pistes sur les
agresseurs est-ce qu'on sait si c'est
ultra gauche ultra droite c'était des
gens qui étaient en train de former une
casserole une casserole mais tout à
l'heure
député Renaissance qui attendait pas la
fin de l'enquête encore une fois moi
j'ai pas les éléments pour vous
l'affirmer de manière définitive mais
donc c'était les gens qui étaient en
train de former une casserole et lui car
le livre député Renaissance il ciblait
l'extrême gauche alors une dizaine de
personnes donc ce sont dirigées vers
notre boutique du centre ville d'Amiens
après la prise de parole du président à
la télévision qui faisait partie d'un
groupe de manifestants qui sont
rassemble régulièrement devant l'hôtel
de ville la dit et colon nous foute la
paix la boutique ne fait pas de
politique on n'a rien à voir avec la
politique économique et sociale menée
par dans le pays Emmanuel Macron n'a
aucune part dans notre commerce je ne
comprends pas toutes ces personnes qui
continuent à noirceler certaines
personnes appellent même au boycott de
nos magasins et de nos produits elles
mélangent tout Brigitte Macron a réagi
également je suis en solidarité totale
avec ma famille en rapport constant
depuis hier 23 avec Jean-Baptiste et
Jean Alexandre il y a plusieurs reprises
dénoncées cette violence qui ne peut que
mener au pire Jean-Baptiste a eu le
courage d'affronter la lâcheté la bêtise
et la violence d'un groupe que je laisse
à la justice le soin de qualifier à nous
tous de réagir en rappelant les valeurs
fondamentales de respect de tolérance
qui font ce que nous sommes je serai
toujours au côté de ceux qui sont
attachés à ces valeurs essentielles je
les tiens de mes parents je les partage
avec mes frères et sœurs et j'accueil de
les transmettre alors c'est vrai que
voilà alors je vous dis on peut être on
peut ne pas être d'accord mais là faire
ça c'est 0 c'est 0 c'est 0 nul 2 ce qui
va être intéressant c'est que là je
pense qu'ils sont clairement identifiés
c'est une vraie violence on va voir
qu'est-ce que la réponse de la justice
parce que on nous dit toujours dans les
manifestations oui mais ils étaient
cagoulés on n'est pas sûr que ce soit
eux et c'est souvent les arguments des
avocats là moi j'attends vraiment
impatiemment
ils sont 8 6 hommes et deux femmes et de
femmes sept majeurs et un mineur
d'accord cette majeur est un milieu donc
que vous parliez des des réactions
politiques c'est vrai et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a réagit très tard c'est ce
que tout le monde dit après 18h30 donc
voilà et c'est vrai que regarder les
réactions
c'est vraiment c'est impossible de faire
ça et par ailleurs déjà les attaques
contre les élus sont-ils admissibles
mais alors contre la famille c'est
encore pire la bannière la plus absolue
voilà on règle pas des différents comme
ça je suis stupéfait par cette nouvelle
forme de violence une de plus les
agressions physiques les violences
envers les élus envers leurs familles
sont inacceptables ça va maintenant
extrêmement loin je pense que ce type
d'agissement doit être très sévèrement
sanctionné par la justice j'ai été
moi-même et vous le savez pendant de
très nombreuses années
victimes moi et ma famille d'ailleurs de
violence de menaces sans que d'ailleurs
à l'époque ça ne suscite d'indignation
alors voilà donc on voit les réactions
je vous dis c'est contre-productif de
faire ça complètement vous voulez faire
passer des messages c'est exactement ce
qu'il faut pas faire et tu vois moi ça
m'énerve moi d'entendre ça là les
attaques contre excuse-moi je prends les
attaques contre les élus c'est
l'admissible les attaques contre tout le
monde c'est au dessus des attaques c'est
découvrir là c'est tout le monde a
l'impression quand ça leur arrive à eux
oh là là les attaques contre les élus et
là c'est tout bord politique qui
condamne parce que là on touche à leur
famille donc là il commence à flipper
mais tous les jours on reçoit des gens
ici qui se font tabassés une vieille
dame qui se fait tabasser par des hommes
de 16 ans c'est le sujet c'est quelqu'un
qui se fait tabasser mais comme c'est
quelqu'un qui a de la famille des élus
là attention
c'est Sandrine Rousseau
dans l'ambiance dans laquelle on est
quand vous êtes élu vous avez plus de
chance de vous faire attaquer non vous
n'êtes pas c'est faux c'est bon c'est
pas le débat c'est pas de faire attaquer
dans la rue que quand
les élus explose
il y a 8 personnes donc interpellé grâce
aux images de vidéosurveillance elles
sont actuellement garde à vue et pour y
passer on comparution immédiate c'est ça
oui alors la garde à vue peut durer 24
heures de plus donc on verra si elle est
renouvelée ils peuvent passer en
comparution immédiate absolument je lui
ai dit tout à l'heure il reste jusqu'à 3
ans de prison et 45000 € d'amende
maximum alors pour vraiment qu'il y a
plein de gens je vous jure que c'est
vrai qu'ils me disent c'est qui
exactement comme ça on va redire je vous
dis celui qui a été agressé c'est
Jean-Baptiste trogneux c'est le petit
neveu de Brigitte Macron il gère donc
une chocolaterie son père ces gens
Alexandre c'est le neveu lui c'est le
neveu euh Brigitte Macron et Emmanuel
Macron et donc le grand oncle par
alliance de Jean-Baptiste qui a été
agressé et l'oncle par alliance de Jean
Alexandre le papa de celui qui a été
agressé c'est bon on a on a tout en tête
vous êtes comment là-dessus c'est bon
alors comment il va mais son père a
donné de ses nouvelles il a passé un
scanner forcément quand on a été au
niveau de la de la tête du ventre et des
jambes on peut pas aller bien donc il y
a des côtes cassés il y aurait aussi des
doigts fracturés voilà il a passé un
scanner il est à l'hôpital c'est
évidemment son père qui donne de ses
nouvelles et qui quelque part répond aux
médias quand on cherche à avoir des
informations sur l'état de son fils
puisque évidemment son fils est à
l'hôpital est dans l'incapacité de le
faire d'accord là il est donc ça ça a
vite est-ce que parce que vous savez
qu'on s'imagine tous et comment ça a
dégénéré en fait mais c'est parce que
qui a été encore une fois au premier
étage il vit au premier étage de sa
chocolaterie quand il a vu que des gens
étaient en train de prendre des
poubelles pour aller fracasser sa
chocolaterie il est descendu pour
essayer de s'interposer et donc face à
lui il s'est retrouvé avec 10 bons
hommes en face de lui et évidemment ils
se sont jetés sur lui à discount donc en
8 contre un plutôt enfin vu qu'il y a 8
gardes à vue donc voilà oui donc voilà
comme ça c'est facile a voulu
s'interposer pour essayer de défendre
son magasin et ce qui se passe c'est ce
qu'on dit là le soir c'est ce qu'on dit
là on dit il faut que la justice quand
tu attaque à 10 contrats à un mec faut
que la justice elle bouge et quand on
nous dit ça on est dit ouais c'est pas
vous vous commandez pas d'accord sauf
que des commerçants qui sont agressés
vous pouvez me dire ce que vous voulez
il y en a partout tous les jours en
France Suisse de petit-fils d'arrière de
petit-fils de neveux de la famille
trogniopa il y en a des commerçants qui
sont assez tout le temps à 10 contre un
et là vous me faites passer pour un fou
je suis pas fou là c'est bien que ça
mette en lumière alors c'est pas bien
qu'il soit pas grave agresser et on
condamne mais c'est bien de voir en
lumière le cinéma que ça prend quand
c'est comme des commerçants moi j'en
connais plein qui se font agresser même
pendant les manifs j'en connais plein
mais on en parle pas donc c'est
peut-être la justice qu'il faut changer
quand 10 mètres après un mec faut
peut-être pas leur dire attention c'est
pas bien ce que tu as fait tu es méchant
normalement et il faut il faut des
sanctions je sais pas si
[Applaudissements]